hey what's good Jesus hey what's going
on what the [__] was that
is Bill birth and it's time for the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast and I I'm just
checking in on you just check it it on
yeah sorry I just woke up I'm at a frog
in my throat Oh Billy no vice
William without twelve days in here no
booze no cigars although you wouldn't
know what that froggen said my throat no
nothing
ah he's being a billy angel I'm gonna
open for Criss Angel out there and
[__] Vegas I'm gonna sit there and
just wag my finger at everybody in the
crowd tell a mother living a life of
vice I got to tell you people when you
find Christ I got the mornings the
mornings are the best when you lived a
vice free life the night before you wake
up it's amazing the birds are singing a
little louder there's a few more nooks
and crannies in your [__] English
muffin you just sit there watching the
melting into it yeah I you know the
mornings are break I'm bored out of my
[__] mind at night out of my mind
bored anyways let's let's but you know
here's one for sobriety one of those
[__] poor bastards at AAA to sit
there our doughnuts and smoking
cigarettes they need something they got
to trying to get a buzz nicotine sugar
something to break up the [__]
monotony yeah let me Gais [__] to
glaze the [__] jelly doughnut just
shoving it down their piehole
that's the worst thing about opening
Pandora's box because once you [__]
do that then you just know how much fun
you could be having you know he's just
sitting around playing Fantan or
something like that drinking a goddamn
Arnold Palmer you know I remember one
time I was hanging out with this guy I'm
not gonna name the name of the person
but he was hanging out with this super
[__] legendary famous [__] rock
star the dude had never got married
never had any kids or whatever and I
remember hanging out with that guy and
he like he could not it was all these
beautiful women around he was barely
looking at him he could not have been
more bored because he had gone so far
down that [__] road like what
literally what it took at that point to
even keep the pilot like going in his
[__] eyes I'm not gonna sit here with
this [__] hang on a second sorry I
had to clear my throat there what a [__]
did I hit stop instead of pause now I
gotta edit those two things together you
know what it is it's when you're living
as clean as I am the toxins through
years of abuse start to come to the
surface and your body is ridding them
cleansing them anyways yes to this guy
he was just like there wasn't any woman
in there that could turn his [__]
head there wasn't a joke that could make
him smile this guy ages he just he went
too far
went too far down the hall he got pulled
out and now he's just sitting there just
[__] bored you know I mean how the
[__] you know wouldn't you participate
in like an orgy and you're the only male
participant I just don't understand like
where you you know what the [__] does
that guy do hey you want to go to brunch
you don't
hey let's go let's go let's go to a game
let's go to this arena that you sold out
and had an orgy and let's go watch your
other people [__] chase a puck you
want to go through that that's like
nothing you could suggest to this guy
he'd have to you know what that that guy
like his next [__] move to get his
adrenaline going would probably be to do
that Red Bull jump we're just falling
from outer space anyways I don't know
what the [__] I'm talking about but
that's that's that's what you expect so
what you expect out that's what I expect
out of this podcast and that's what's
wrong with America Americans podcasting
with absolutely no expectations on how
well the show is gonna go alright let's
talk let's talk Yankees Red Sox
oh it's heating up again the Red Sox
raped the Yankees 14 to 1 on Monday
oh whatever was it Monday I'm sorry
Tuesday alright remember I remember when
I was a kid they should say these runs
for tomorrow like you can save runs and
then yesterday our Staten pitcher price
he got hurt or something so our pitching
was [__] yesterday and the Yankees ended
up winning which is fine there's like 9
million games left but I think it was
really stupid of the Red Sox to get into
a fight with them that fight was was
good for the Yankees because they're not
as good a team they got bats but they
don't have pitching and pitching is
always gonna win come October you don't
need to get involved in that stupid [__]
and and we did so now they have now
they're all [__] they're all [__]
excited you don't do that you know the
guy wants to slide like that I mean up
until last year that was legal who gives
a [__] who gives a [__]
to strike the guy out have them sit down
with this big [__] stupid face I hate
baseball players in this stupid fighting
where everybody comes out and piles on
each other and nobody does the you lucky
you holding me back better than [__]
baseball players maybe basketball
players I don't know
that's stupid after the fight and
there's like two guys holding you back
and then you still have to do that
stupid charge you know you're not gonna
get there it's over
button your shirt and go to the showers
but anyways yeah we were getting killed
and we still liked it was almost like
the Yankees couldn't score enough run so
we have bats and we have pitching we're
in a great position why would we get
involved in that tomfoolery I mean this
is sober bill talking oh you know what's
so stupid is in the middle of fight you
just hear this guy going
Red Sox fan can we retire that stupid
chant already it's like it's it's like
[__] Manchurian Candidate level from
like the second anything happens you got
to start chanting that not that Yankee
fans are innocent with that stupid 1918
forever and then when they when that
chant was over then they switched it to
Boston sucks which is the worst chant
ever I don't know there's so much of it
that just makes me want to hit mute the
Sweet Caroline the Yankee suction all of
that stuff it just says to me that
people do not think for themselves and
that [__] mob mentality I don't like
the Yankees but we beat them the movie
is over it's over roll credits we won
the World Series they are now reduced to
co-ed hey remember what we did last
century remember that I mean that's what
they've been reduced to why would you
like
make them actually feel that they hold
some sort of position by continuing to
chant Yankees suck they don't suck
they're a good [__] team and I love
the way that they've built from their
farm team and then added that big free
agent from Miami or Florida her [__]
Tuscaloosa whatever the [__] they call
themselves now open chobe the Okeechobee
Marlins I like what they've done they
don't suck and I think that Aaron Boone
is gonna be a great manager and I look
forward to the competition between both
teams then who gives a [__] either we
win or they win or somebody else wins
who gives a [__]
just enjoy the [__] game don't go
there and be a [__] mouth breather and
for the love of God will you sit down
when they play that stupid Sweet
Caroline how many [__] times can you
do it the [__] Yankee fence at this
say good [__] YMCA I'd you know what I
win it I should go this hard you know
it's for the kids it's tradition it's
what brings people together I don't know
I thought the Yankees did pretty good
before they had to sing that [__]
song during the seventh inning they're
stupid grounds crew doing the little
twirly twirl oh my god I'm such a [__]
na anyways I'm sure Dan Shaughnessy is
very excited that it's heated up again
and he can actually write about the
sport that he knows about and ignore the
Bruins playoff run why do I always pick
on Dan Shaughnessy I don't hate that guy
I just like picking on him because I
will never forgive that [__] guy for
after 2004 when we won and then 2005 we
were in first place in September we got
a bunch of injuries which clearly
affected the team and then the
$200,000,000 Yankees I believe ended up
coming and passing us and Shaughnessy's
like is the curse back I was like right
there you're not a Red Sox fan you're
just not you're a guy making money off
of misery
you're your own little corporation you
know profiting off of war in a Sports
sense Jesus bill you went big there yes
I did
and I'll do it again anyways the Bruins
playoff run starts tonight and I have a
lot of nerve given Shaughnessy [__]
considering I maybe watch four games
this year now that I got the little one
and we're playing the Toronto Maple
Leafs and those poor bastards are gonna
have to [__] endure the highlight
reel of what happened the last time we
played them and just know that I was at
that [__] game
I actually know something it's funny I
feel like Maple Leaf fans hate the
Bruins and I don't hate the Maple Leafs
I actually like the Maple Leafs I hate
the Canadians that's it and a couple of
knee breakers on the Penguins other than
that and not even if the Penguins have
knee breakers it's just that they then
turn around and complain but somebody
gets a little rough on the other team
they were attacking Sidney they bug me
that's it other than that I don't have a
problem to anybody I'm looking forward
to wonderful seven-game series we'll see
how it goes
but comes on at four o'clock here I'm
balancing my entire [__] schedule is
that it said I always say my entire
[__] schedule is it's gonna be based
around that my daughter takes a nap from
three to five so I figure I'll get to
watch the first period and then and then
I'll probably be [__] who's kidding no
I'm actually flying to the tomorrow I'm
flying out to Charlotte for the rough
and rowdy fight I'm going to be
commentating watching regular people's
Americans on Americans fighting there's
going to be over 40 fights and I'm
feeling that this is going to be like
when I did the Joe Rogan Doug Stanhope
and
the universe podcast on election night
that's the vibe that I feel like is
gonna be going on so I'm just going to
be trying to get in as many jokes as I
can it's already entertaining while
getting out of the way of the action
I've never done any set like this I
remember when I was a kid my mother
thought I should be a sports commentator
I don't think she pictured me doing
starting my career in an event like this
but I'm looking forward to it I really
am and it's a $15.00 pay-per-view unless
you wait til the day of so today's the
last day we can get off like $15.99
after that it goes up to $19.99 but if
you're a college kid you know a couple
two three your friends throw in like
five and a half bucks each get yourself
a Domino's Pizza and whatever else you
want to do as Mike Golic would say an
adult beverage and enjoy the fights
anyways
plowing ahead here I've started my
workout my serious my theory aswer Kout
regimen to somehow stave off the fact
that I'm turning 50 and [__] June the
big five oh but Papa you [__] [__]
old your [__] balls hey Dad to the
bar
I actually feel fortunate to be to have
made it this long consider bunch of my
friends did not and then also the
direction we seem to be going here why
are we bombing Syria why are we gonna do
this how much further it into this
[__] Middle East [__] are we gonna go
I don't understand why France US Russia
all of these [__] people why the [__]
do we keep intervening over there you
know what I mean these people have been
fighting with each other forever and
then we're gonna come in a hey settle
down settle down give us the oil settle
down
you shouldn't do that to what another
give us the oil stop doing that
Frances President Emanuel McCall says he
has proof that the Syrian government
attacked the town of DOMA with chemical
weapons last weekend he said he would
decide in due course whether to respond
with airstrikes I don't know how these
gangs world leaders do that [__] it's
like you know you don't respond with
airstrikes and they're not all gonna
land on the people that did it and then
you have to go to bed that night going
like well I think most of them landed on
the people that were guilty you know the
others landed in a food court I think
that's why they aged although I think
Donald Trump is gonna age wonderfully
during his presidency because I don't
think he really understands the
ramifications of what the [__] it is
that he's saying or doing
who the [__] tweets about when a
country's gonna strike another country
isn't that supposed to kind of be a
secret or the way he's trying to do the
three-card Monte it could be now it
could be not at all or maybe later you
know it's funny there's probably Syrian
people actually looking and his and his
tweets you know like like looking at it
like like they found clues sorry I just
got this [__] email these goddamn
[__] state of Wisconsin just hit me
with this huge goddamn tax bill I was
like [__] do I owe you guys all that
goddamn money yeah I know I know why
they hit me with that [__] I know why I
know why cuz we spending money in this
country and a bunch of other [__] so
that I come down there and they [__]
pull the pants down they give all
freckles a good spanking before I leave
the state that's like a new thing all of
these scams do you know in Pittsburgh
they had an entertainment tax for a
while if you were an entertainer if you
spun plates and you went to Pittsburgh
they taxed you for entertaining people
literally doing your job when I was in
st. Louis one time I was in a hotel and
I actually took the time to look at the
bill
the city of st. Louis or the state of
Missouri charged me what the [__] that
they call it an occupation tax on the
room they tax me for occupying the room
they just shakin like [__] 30 20 30
bucks out of your pocket we'll take that
thank you for coming here did you get a
chance to visit the [__] OHS I don't
know I'll tell you it's all the goddamn
scam what am I gonna do am I gonna take
on a whole [__] state Michael Moore
would do it alright the Penguins Jesus
Christ what they went 18 to nothing
against the [__] sly is not to get to
watch any of the hockey last night I was
editing season 3 of f is for family I
think I'm gonna tell you right now and I
could say this with total confidence
this is without a doubt our best season
it's a it's a noticeable jump between
the first and second seasons and I can't
wait for you guys to see it but it's
animation so I'll be like Donald Trump
you could be seeing these episodes soon
or maybe later possibly not at all or
maybe they're on right now I should get
a giant [__] toupee like he doesn't
matter pay I think he did a comb-over
and then he did some hair plugs and they
didn't work but now the hair plugs are
better and I think maybe they worked but
then he just has to kind of commit to
the comb-over you know I actually think
he kind of has nice hair you know the
way he gets dyed all golden when it goes
Orange it's bad bone he is like the
golden sort of [__] stray cat's
haircut you know we're gonna bomb this
town bomb it it's a dam I think it's a I
think it's a good look I could see him
with like an upright bass I want to get
one of those [__]
would you guys do if somehow I got
[__] I actually caved and I got
[__] hair plugs right and I had a
giant red stray cat's [__] hairdo out
of nowhere
no not out of nowhere you would you
would notice it like pictures of me
after shows going what's going on with
the top of burrs head and I refused to
like when someone's slowly transitioning
there's that thing of like wow that's an
interesting outfit and then people start
you Trent and then finally they'd say
yeah you know what I am I would I would
do what Bruce Jenner did except of my
hair alright but what if I never [__]
addressed it what if I never went on and
talked to Diane's store Sawyer you know
and just sat there going I was the story
I was the story what if I never did that
and refused to ever address my new
Quaffle [__] hair and I tried to just
I just I erased all my podcast any
[__] evidence of me ever admitting
that I went bald
then I would just say that I've just
refused to you know like Turkey when
they refused to say that never happened
if you say it happened you go into jail
how much would I be getting heckled if I
came out with a [__] Ric Flair
haircut oh [__] you know something I was
talking about MotoGP and the was at the
Argentine Grand Prix is that where it
was what a [__] race that was I don't
even I don't even I haven't watched
racing enough to even understand what
the [__] happened and I was dealing with
my kids and all of a sudden the race
starts and there was like one person in
the front row nobody in like 30 rows
back or something like that then a bunch
of people in the back Marc Marquez had
stalled his bike so according to the
rules he had to leave and go restarted
or something and he was driving around
in circles refusing to [__] leave so
then he ended up those race starts
and he gets penalized or penalized
depending on what part of the country
you're from he got penalized he goes to
the back of the race and this [__]
guy just wrote he was like I swear to
God he was like 40 seconds ahead of
everybody who's gonna win the race going
away it was one of those tracks where it
was it was still wet or whatever and he
was just riding way faster than
everybody else I don't know how and they
say hey buddy buddy you uh you've got to
go to the back of there this is so
stupid I didn't want to talk about you
got to go to the back of the race so
they sent him all the way to the back go
to the pits first and then they sent him
to the back of the race because he
[__] ran over this guy you know he
basically went to go past somebody he's
he's bumping him out of the way like
they're in cars except they're on
motorcycles and he would wave like sorry
about that
and continue on then like hey buddy you
got to go to the back of the [__]
race right the first time I think that
they he bumped into somebody made him
sit there in the pits
I don't remember they think they
penalize this guy so many [__] times
long story short he went from first
place all the way to last it's now he's
blowing by everybody and he gets up to
Valentino Rossi who's basically the
Wayne Gretzky the Lewis Hamilton the
[__] person you're not supposed to
touch a [__] with and he's trying to get
around him and Valentino Rossi's like
[__] you you're not getting around me
and rather than waiting for a
straightaway he tried to pass him on a
turn and he just [__] slammed into
him and Valentino got pushed to the
outside and he had control the bike but
then he went on the grass and he wiped
out he fell off his bike and Marquez
turns around waves like sorry right
Valentino gets up he's Italian right and
then he [__] picks his bike up now
he's ride now all the Valentino Rossi
fans like what the [__] is with this guy
Marc Marquez gets penalized again I
believe and so at the end of the [__]
race márquez walks down with somebody
else to Valentino's pit area whatever
call it the pageant I forget what they
call it because of the P and Valentino's
like oh my god I am like so not talking
to you some of the mechanic of the chief
[__] Stewart Stewart us down there
something he's yelling at Marquez and
Marquez ends up walking away and then
Valentino Rossi said he wasn't man
enough to come down by himself he came
down with somebody else
bla bla bla bla bla and I'm sitting
there agreeing with Valentino Rossi and
then all of a sudden everybody starts
sending all these [__] highlights
from like three years earlier when Rossi
basically donkey kicked Marc Marquez off
his [__] bike or out of the goddamn
race or something like that so it's it
just seemed like Lewis Hamilton behavior
where it's like it's okay if I do it but
if you do it you're a [__] [__]
and now I'm gonna have a hissy fit about
it so I think I like Marc Marquez better
you know I respect Rossi you know the
little I know about the sport being the
legend that he is but I like Marquez
[__] it if he did that two years earlier
yeah pass him at a turn knock him off
his bike and give them a wave who gives
a [__] I'm telling you guys you're
missing out on this is this all of this
took place in like 25 laps you can watch
your race in like 40 minutes and you can
watch these these unbelievable this
unbelievable [__] sport I can't even
tell you how sold I am on MotoGP just to
let you know there's MotoGP two and
three and they're all going to get
recorded and there's going to be like
five recordings of them and there's a
chance your your your recorder is going
to shut off which is what would have
happened to me I would have missed the
end of the [__] race but fortunately
I got to watch it live I don't
understand trying to tape one of those
races is practically impossible so I
have to make sure I don't I don't lose
the one here the MotoGP of the Americas
is what they call it why don't they say
they say Argentina you know they say
they say Italy why can't we say USA you
know what do we embarrassed the Americas
where is it Canada Mexico
Glynn Islands anyways check it out if
you get a chance you know usually this
is the time when I actually do a read or
something and that's just I don't have
any advertising you know what I mean I'm
like that Real Housewife on the Real
Housewives that just trashes too many
[__] people and then that you know
just doesn't have any friends anymore
that's where the advertising is slowly
going okay on this podcast and I am now
that I've cleaned up my act as far as my
you know offstage behavior I am now
going to clean up this podcast in an
effort to try to get by advertising back
I am NOT going to have any sort of
opinions look I just stop right now and
just talk about how amazing and strong
women are and how whatever look at your
your girlfriend or wife right now and
just look at whatever she's doing and
just realize how strong she is and
really just take time in your day to
understand how amazing women are and how
right they are and how they do nothing
wrong whatsoever ever and if they do
something wrong just know that it's
because of something that you did I want
everybody to close their eyes and talk
to Jesus right now should I go that far
no I think they'll be too limiting I
think if I just say positive things
about women
I can't do this thank you [__] annoys
the [__] out of me
a clutch is there anything more annoying
than a clutch it gives my outfit I don't
have any pockets can you hold all my
[__] hey why don't you bring money get
[__] bags why don't you bring a bunch
of one of those recycling bags once you
throw that over your [__] outfit
maybe you'll be making some new fashion
statement right like back in the day
when women will wear business suits and
[__] sneakers put on something nice
and then have like a little [__]
grocery bag you don't stick stick all
your [__] in there you giant [__] L
[__] cell phone I already have us my
cell phone in my pocket you want to mean
to radiate [__] both sides of my
scrotum I mean not to mention my taint
do you have any sort of consideration
for me whatsoever
am I just a [__] pack mule once you
get a smaller phone you're gonna walk
around with a clutch I say you go back
to a flip phone that's what I say that's
my big controversial [__] take on
this Thursday playoff hockey tonight
everybody playoff hockey the third game
of the Red Sox Yankees 90 million games
that we're gonna play this year I got 50
bucks on every game with my booking
agent and Paul virzi and I called the
two of them the panic brothers because
that first game they will literally go
and like with that and I like God was so
screwed bullpens admit the Yankees had
major problems and they'd like literally
the next game it's just like do we go to
the World Series and that all of a
sudden [__] Hanley Ramirez hits that
grand slam and we go down from being
like [__] down eight to two and now
it's eight to six and then it's all of a
sudden it's like if we blow this the
bullpens the problem it's like dude this
is a hundred and fifty games left I
can't [__] do this but it's so funny
to watch Yankee fans act like how Red
Sox fans used to act they don't have any
swagger anymore
they're a bunch of [__] nervous
Nellie's it's tremendous which is why
once again we shouldn't have gotten to
that stupid fight with them stupid well
I give them an emotional point to rally
around you're the better goddamn team
but it doesn't mean that the better
team's gonna win it doesn't mean it
because when you start getting involved
in that stupid [__] it's [__]
baseball nobody's gonna get hurt
everybody's gonna come running out I
always wanted to talk to people like who
come running out of the bullpen you know
is that like annoying that by the time
you get there like the fights already
been over for [__] three minutes you
know and you can tell the way they come
running out it's like what are you gonna
just you're gonna be sitting there
you're not pitching that day right
you're blowing bubbles you're coming up
with [__] games you can play to get
through the [__] guy I'm thinking I'm
looking at something green and your
buddy's going out of green monster no
that person's Red Sox st. Patty's Day
hat no right and all of a sudden you
like is that a fight is that a fighting
the phone [__] rings hey buddy yeah I
don't know if you notice but there's
like a 40 on 40 fight about about a
football field away why don't you come
out it's good it's gonna look good for
the team and he gets up without [__]
stretching and you see him jog out there
they're not gonna come running out their
full [__] full speed they're gonna
pull a hamstring they're gonna throw a
punch and [__] up their hand they can't
they're pictures they're pictures you
you you're looking at a Ken doll it's
it's got it has no [__] no genitalia
it's running out with that every once in
a while you see somebody come running
out that's usually the [__] warm-up
catcher that guy will come flying out of
there he's got to do something to keep
make sure he stays on the goddamn team
right that guy only catches the
knuckleballer he's like oh Jesus I get
to do something right
anyways rough and rowdy Shalit North
Carolina in the house that Ric Flair
built I cannot [__] wait and I am
actually going out to buy a little
have a dash for the [__] I'm going
all out for this thing and it's gonna be
a great [__] time alright it's gonna
be as great as every woman on the planet
is they're just great people every
single one of them none of them needs to
do any sort of self-examination
anything that they're doing it's because
of the man that's in their life or maybe
a man who isn't even in their life maybe
a man that they've never even met before
is the reason for their behavior that's
it everybody have a great weekend and go
[__] yourselves you [__] and I will I
will talk to you on Monday
I look forward to high-level competition
tonight between the Boston Red Sox and
the New York Yankees all right
see you
[Music]
[Applause]
like a boss here's the story gotta beat
Marsha got to get closer than a quarter
of an inch remember that when Greg Brady
is driving that [__] Caprice Classic
whatever the [__] they had whipping it
around the parking lot closer than an
engineer beat Marshall making fun of how
broads can't drive one of my favorite
[__] episodes now that's a typical
male chauvinist reaction you're
prejudiced against women drivers I'm not
not as long as they stay off the roads
it's not prejudiced is just that men are
naturally superior drivers my two
favorite episodes was the first half of
that Brady Bunch episode when Greg Brady
was bringing the [__] hammer down it
was going let me tell you three [__]
stepsister [__] something none of you
broads know how to drive and that
includes your mother who I'm banging by
the way who I'm banging by the way all
right with their weird-ass haircut
whatever the [__] you know but yeah I
had a date with him and you know it was
I I kind of felt like I was if you were
in school and I were the teacher did
anybody ever have that [__] hair cut
out other than her I mean that is like I
don't know what it was
she took like Moe from the Three Stooges
haircut and then she put a [__] sort
of mullet that she did a little flip to
on the back anyways let's get back to
you broads you know not a [__] Drive
that goes for you with the [__]
speech impediment you don't know how to
[__] Drive Jan with your awful
[__] Hasidic Jew [__] curls I
don't know what you're trying to do you
know and and in Marsha who I don't know
why I'm not banging you some reason it
skipped over you and started banging
your mother right none of you [__]
can [__] Drive and I'm watching this
episode going this see Greg Brady says
[__] Greg Barry [__] Fonzie you know
with this stupid [__] you know
spinning around and punching a jukebox
so a place Shaboom Shaboom i don't give
a [__] about that I like Greg Brady
you know for as much as Fonzie was
talking [__] he was always nice to the
ladies any that's that's seventh grade
game with the woman
[Applause]
Greg Brady that's that's how Greg ended
up [__] their mom cuz he didn't give
a [__] you didn't give a [__]
Greg [__] you Carol you're not my mother
you know how to drive either oh my god
took him in that [__] groovy attic
they had started blowing him that's why
his hair got all curly so anyways that
episode he's telling these [__]
broads that they don't know how to drive
and then in the end of course cuz they
always had to cater to women these nerdy
[__] writers you know and then the
end they [__] you know Marcia goes
around this stupid [__] track and
they had a cone with a little egg on it
you guys have seen this and she [__]
you know I forget whatever Marcia jokes
in the beginning and then in the end
just to [__] even it outs everybody's
happy and they could sell tide during
the commercials they have Greg [__] up
and knock the egg off that's that's what
I was trying to get to wasn't that what
I was trying to get to that went on so
[__] long I can't even remember all
I'm saying is that the guy you want you
don't it doesn't [__] matter how many
yards you throw in the regular season it
doesn't [__] matter
[Music]
that's all the song
it's the Monday morning podcast from
Monday April 12 2010 and I'm actually
just putting this up here right now to
let you guys know that I'm not doing a
podcast this week I apologize I'm
calling in sick all right
I'm [__] you know remember 1 Cal Cal
Ripkin voluntarily took himself out of
that game and he ended his streak I'm
ending my podcast streak this is the
first week that I I'll ever willingly
not do a [__] podcast you know it's
like an NFL football the big question is
can you go if we tape it up and we
freeze it can you go and this is the
first time I could tell you no I can't I
can't go this week everybody I apologize
so we're gonna have a substitute this
week I'm gonna pass the mic I'm [__]
with you I really should have had
someone stand in um I'm spent all right
I'm back to drinking I'm disgusted with
myself I was in Atlanta this week I
didn't drink Wednesday and I didn't
drink Thursday and then Friday was
coming along and I was tired now my
buddy was opening for me and I had a
couple of drinks I had two beers then I
switched to water which is a great thing
and it usually makes me stop but the
thing was as I left the punch line in
Atlanta that's where I was at I was at
the punch line and I walked across the
street to this club 290 and well I don't
know somewhere walking from the punch
line across the parking lot to Club 290
I then switched back to two alcohol I
don't know what happened Jesus Christ I
hear my phone ringing in the background
how many times gonna ring before you
realize either I'm not home or I'm not
picking it up
it's probably some [__] telemarketer
now Jesus there you go first and finally
quit
so anyways anyway I walk over there and
people are drinking so I add a couple
more Budweiser's and then the [__]
bartender over there if you guys live in
the Atlanta area and I feel really bad
telling you this alright because it's
such a cool [__] thing that I don't
want it to get ruined and become
anything touristy you know I can't even
what the name of the thing was just go
in there there's a bartender named Tommy
and just ask him if he can spin the
wheel alright this guy out of nowhere
says to me and Paul virzi who's opening
up for me who [__] killed all weekend
he just pulls out this drum head and
it's got an arrow and has a bunch of
[__] written all around the rim of the
drum head and he goes spin the arrow and
you'd spin it and he I don't mean I was
so drunk I don't know what I got and
Paul spun at first he got something the
guy goes okay you got this then he has
me spin it
and he goes alright you got you know you
got this and then he walks over and he
picks up this I don't know what it is
you know like that thing like that they
put like Jager in you know when you do
like they have Jager on tap you know
those things he basically picked up
something like that that had a door on
the front of it and he just puts it on
top of his head and he's just staring at
us and all of a sudden he opens the door
and he has this dumb cross-eyed look on
his face and he starts singing slash
rapping I don't know what and it doesn't
even sound like English and at the end
of every sentence it kind of [__]
rhymes and right as you start to figure
out what he's saying he stops makes a
weird face and slams the door right in
his face it's the most [__] up thing
when he first did it I was like all
defensive like is this guy gonna make me
look like a [__] [__] and then I
and then right as I caught on that he
was just acting like an idiot he slammed
the door on himself and it was the best
[__] laugh I've had in like three
mark I can't even imitate what he did
and that was just for Paul so now he's
stand he just slammed the door this
[__] thing on his right in his own
face this little door and now he's just
standing there looking at me but he's
not looking at me he's got this [__]
thing on him on his head and I know I'm
next and all of a sudden he opens the
door again he's got that same dumb look
on his face and he said ah bill burr
duppa duppa Dodd has never done today I
can't even [__] do what he was doing
and me and Paul at this point I like
pounding the bar [__] dying laughing
and you didn't want it to end and all of
a sudden he just stops with his [__]
up look on his face and he slams the
door in his face again Club 290 the guys
names Tommy just hang out there I'm
telling you what all the [__] weird
[__] I've seen in bars with people doing
tricks with matchbooks people telling
you jokes and everything was the most
unique [__] thing I've ever seen in
my life and it's called the Club 290
just just go in there whatever that's it
the next night I was gonna bring
actually my video camera and videotape
it and put it up on YouTube but I didn't
want to
YouTube ruins everything because
everything then becomes mainstream and
it can't be it was just this cool
underground thing so what I did to keep
it under ground was not videotape it and
then [__] talk about out of my
podcast what an [__] um so anyway so
I went hard that night and then I stayed
out till like 4:00 in the morning and we
ended up driving out of there and and
Versys going come on hey is anything
open I want to get something neat I'm
like do it I'm not eating this [__]
late actually was like three I got to
sleep by force it was a little bit
before three he goes no no no I guys I
think McDonald's open like dude it's not
gonna be open this late things that guy
right come on just drive up there so I
say [__] it I Drive up there
he sees the lights are on and he you see
that one lonely [__] person standing
in there walking around doing everything
and he's all excited do do the drive use
open yes it's [__] open right so we
go we go to the drive-thru and he's like
dude you gotta get something like nah
dude I'm not getting this [__] I can't
eat this [__] light up - too old to
be eating this light right so we go up
to the drive-thru the guy goes hey
welcome McDonald's can I take your order
and immediately my mouth just starts
going yeah let me get two double
cheeseburgers a small fry and a coke and
virzi just starts laughing at me because
two seconds ago I wasn't gonna get
anything in the second I just started
smelling those fries I said you know
what actually now that I think of it I'm
gonna order about 1280 calories of trans
fats I think that that's what I'm gonna
do so we get our [__] [__] drive back
to the hotel [__] eat it in his room
and then I go to bed you know I wake up
the next day at like 12:30 and I'm not
worth [__] I'm not worth [__] [__] we
get up we go to the Waffle House this is
what I did to my body this week this is
why there's no podcast this week this is
not a podcast okay so if you guys don't
like this podcast don't write me and say
that podcast sucked when you need to say
is your unbelievably long statement
announcing why you weren't gonna do a
podcast sucked all right
get it right there [__] face so yeah we
go into the Waffle House we're both
[__] hungover I've been to the Waffle
House a bunch of times because I travel
this [__] country
Paul virzi has never been to the [__]
Waffle House because he doesn't work
this part of the country much or maybe
he just never went to it which I would
understand because of the piss yellow
sign that they have with the incredibly
bland black font it is um is a question
for you guys in this non podcast what
when you guys look at like fast food
don't you know what like some signs are
like appealing and they make you want to
eat the food or at the very least try it
we haven't an earthquake is that just
wind and having a lot of earthquakes
lately um I thought it was one of those
little ones every once while I get one
of those little ones out here and uh it
just feels like you know if your eyes
are closed at night and you get one of
those you feel like if you opened your
eyes there'd be some guys standing at
the end of your bed just shaking it like
I'm kind of [__] kill you um anyway
so we go which Jesus Christ I got
nothing this is not a podcast everybody
I can't even [__] think right now
I had a muffin a bag of M&Ms of water
and some sort of chicken wrap all
Airport [__] food I've destroyed my
body I think at least two of my organs
have shut down at this point I'm gonna
go with one kidney and see the pancreas
now that's that's the [__] Grand
Central of the organs isn't it what
exactly does the pancreas do that's for
all you geeks out there who let me know
that facetious is not the only word that
has all the vowels in a row you hear
that geeky person who sent me that
[__] email that said the interesting
thing about the word facetious is it's
the only word in the English language
where all the all the vowels not only
all the vowels in the English language
in the word they're actually in order
it's the only word in the English
language I'm sorry to tell you sir
you're actually wrong and I can't
remember what the other word is but at
least two other nerds
mailed me to let me know that you were
wrong so I'm not gonna read the emails
because this is not a podcast this week
I'm taking this week off so what you
need to do is you need to deepen the
level of nerd that you [__] hang out
with before you make an ass of yourself
like that again on the podcast lucky for
you I'm not trashing you on another
podcast or so you would be embarrassed
right now fortunately for you this got
buried on the back page of this non
podcast this week so anyways which I
have fast food restaurant you guys feel
like the sign makes the food look like
the least appealing for me I would go
with the Waffle House because they have
like that piss yellow [__] sign and
they have the plainest black font it's
just horrible absolutely horrible it
makes me sick to my stomach Arby's is
another one that blood orange color that
[__] hat and they're grey roast beef
and by the way I ate there last night at
about [__] 1:00 in the morning Jesus
Christ you know what I used to hate too
was this the subway back in the day when
they had those piss yellow counters in
the newspaper articles all on the walls
remember that they literally had urine
colored tables with newspapers the only
thing was missing was a homeless guy
rolled up in the wallpaper pissing on
the tables that was he that was
basically subconsciously what they were
creating and not only that the pictures
on the wall oh no way no no no no no no
no the newspapers oh I'm [__] this up
the subway used to have pictures of old
New York on it that's what it had wow I
[__] that up the newspapers were
actually the tabletops of the old
Wendy's there's a bunch of guys 41 years
old and older right now [__] punch in
their dashboard going that's where I was
gonna [__] say that I remember that
[__] then you go in there and you don't
you order the triple do you ever one
time you know that's it you remember one
time you know one time I was standing in
line at Wendy's and I was making my girl
crack-up or maybe my girlfriend at the
time I can't even [__] think this
week I was making her laugh her ass off
because I was making fun of
who the [__] orders a triple cheat
triple cheeseburger you know I don't
even know what I was saying but I had
her dying laughing and I was so psyched
that I was making her laugh cuz was
making me feel good I had a crying
laughing then I had said triple
cheeseburger so many [__] times that
when I walked up to the register I ended
up ordering it and then she looked at me
like what the [__] did you do that for
and then I felt stupid for ordering it
but then I also felt you know I didn't
want to be like oh wait wait wait wait
wait I don't want to look like an
[__] and then the gluttonous side of
me is like oh great I can't eat a triple
cheeseburger you know like a fat [__] so
anyways I would go with Arby's and I
would go with the Waffle House signage
so anyways you walk into the Waffle
House and for those of you who have
never been to a Waffle House don't ever
put your elbows on the table because you
won't be able to get them off without
taking off at least two layers of skin
because there's somebody kill me you
know I had an urge to do I'm wearing a
thermal right now I had the urge to take
this thing off and hang myself by the
sleeves
I got nothing I got absolutely nothing
this week
this statement is it's just gonna be a
long statement of so anyways we walk
into the [__] Waffle House and yes I
did lose some energy in my voice I'm
running out of batteries here oh yeah
I'm sweating here we walk into the
Waffle House and we're both [__]
hungover and I've been to the Waffle
House hundreds of times so I already
know the menu Paul on the other hand
does not know the menu so the waitress
comes over and she goes you guys ready
to order and I'm like yeah actually I'm
ready to order so virzi goes into a
[__] panic and it's a big
overwhelming [__] menu they have like
98 different kinds of hash browns
smothered covered [__] sheet [__] on
or whatever the [__] you supposed to say
there that he just you know I order what
I order and then he he didn't know what
the [__] that dope
he's just looking at the pictures
pancakes toast eggs and he finally just
goes yeah do you have uh what are the
order you he ordered eggs benedict
[__] Waffle House you know who the
[__] or debts like trying to order like
a ribeye steak at McDonald's they don't
have it Paul over easy or [__]
scrambled I mean there's like toothless
truckers in there convicted felons has
been rappers it's a it's a [__] but
their waffles are delicious
especially especially when you hung over
their food so fattening I actually had a
little hiccup there as I was just
describing it so anyways and this is a
this is this is the kicker like that
night I have three [__] shows alright
but because I'm a professional I'm able
to push all the feelings that I have of
the horror that I've done to my body
over the last [__] 24 hours I go
onstage kill at 7:00 kill at 10:00
I do I go to do know seven nine and 11
and 11 o'clock show I literally have a
splitting [__] headache and all I can
think of is Jerry Lewis and now we never
ever sat down in his tuxedo pants and he
always gave him a [__] show and I was
like you know instead of what would
Jesus do what would Jerry do he would
give him a show lady
so I plowed through that one and then
that was the end of my weekend so you
probably think in yourself right now
well then why he was shoeing a state in
the bill you [__] you will finish
Saturday it's [__] Monday didn't you
recuperate yesterday no I did not I went
to the Masters yesterday and watched
Phil Mickelson win his third green
jacket and it was an incredible
experience I went to the Superbowl of
golf everybody and after having gone
there and seen how [__] beautiful
that golf course is I don't know why
they don't call the Super Bowl the
Masters of football you know why cuz
nobody [__] watch his golf to the
level that they watched football that's
why I knew
answer that question I'm just trying to
tell you that was a beautiful course and
and basically you don't get tickets to
the Masters alright cuz I want to tell
you guys this is just like Royal Albert
Hall that I saw this is another thing
that if you're into golf you have to do
at some point you don't get tickets what
you do is you get a badge and you have
to get a badge from some sort of dude
who knows a member who knows a [__]
guy who knows a guy
who [__] knew a guy who knew a guy
and when you go to pick up your tickets
you actually [__] at least we did we
actually drove to somebody's house
I remember I thought it's gonna be like
some will call [__] and it wasn't we're
driving through this neighborhood
and I'm looking at the addresses and I'm
like I think it's the next hop it's a
house I must be on the wrong Street and
then I look and there's this woman
sitting in a garage waving at us and I
was like all right well either this is
the place where we're supposed to be or
this is the friendliest [__]
neighborhood I've ever been to or maybe
I look like one of her neighbors or
maybe she has a rape fantasy and she
ordered a redhead cuz you know how many
reddit gigolos are out there everybody
I'm telling you we're in demand we're
we're dying off well like the white
rhinos of [__] human beings people
are trying to bang us before we
disappear let me think about it think
about the dodo bird think about if you
actually stuck your dick in a dodo bird
neither did the [__] you Trump every
story in a bar I [__] something that
doesn't exist anymore
what are you a necrophiliac no you
[__] [__] I [__] a dodo bird
anyways now right there I would have
complained if that was on a regular
podcast I would have complained about
that last bit there but fortunately this
is not a podcast I'm just issuing a
statement that I do not have the energy
to [__] do this this week so anyways
we get these [__] badges and they
actually bring you into the house we sit
in this library and I'm sitting there
and this woman is debriefing me about
these badges okay I'm already freaked
out about going to the masters because
there's a level of whiteness and a level
of education that even intimidates me as
white as I am now
now if aesthetically AE s th e TI c al
ly aesthetically I mean if I spelt it
right but I know how to spell it when
I'm not [__] brain-dead
it's one of my spelling words let's get
smart America
aesthetically I'm very white alabaster
if you asked my girlfriend that's how
she describes me porcelain desk
that's how white I am but there's this
is the different kind of white this
isn't a Thurston Howell the third kind
of white and Ivy League kind of white
Illuminati you know rubbin elbows with
the Kennedys we summer in the Hamptons
we have a house on Martha's Vineyard you
know when Jesus comes back he's gonna
have to be buzzed into our house after
he talks to our lawyer our lawyer will
be present when Jesus judges me like
that level of [__] white so I went on
the internet and I actually was like the
I know there's a dress code here and the
last thing I want to do when I go to a
place like that is I don't want to come
in there and disrespect the place I
don't give a [__] about the approval of
those people but you know what I mean
you going to that place
it's an unbelievable golf event I
respect the history of an Arnold Palmer
Jack Nicklaus Ben Hogan all that type of
stuff so I want to go there and show it
the respect that it deserves
all right and also I don't want to walk
in there looking like a [__] bum so I
go on the internet and I check out the
dress code it's literally college shirt
no jeans allowed all this [__] so I for
the first time in about I think 20 years
I actually when I had some sort of a
suit job I actually bought a pair of
Dockers
[Laughter]
Dockers everybody at least I went with
the black ones I did not buy khaki I
refuse to ever wear khaki there's only
two people in the world wear khaki
animal experts and date rapists all
right
I'm not wearing khaki so I bought a pair
of black Dockers and I had this blue
like Nike golf shirt and then I had the
Tiger Woods the Tiger Woods Nike hat the
black one with the red V why am i acting
like I'm walking the red carpet from my
movie date night that came out last
weekend which is a huge [__] hit
everybody I'm so [__] psyched date
night was a huge hit it made a ton of
[__] money and if you went out and
saw it I want to say thank you because I
hope it's such a huge hit that they make
a [__] sequel and maybe I'll be able
to repot reprise my role as Detective
Walsh you know maybe I'll be a belt I'll
turn bad in the second one like [__]
Kehoe in another 48 hours remember that
I'll grow one of those walrus mustaches
I don't give a [__] it's the first movie
I've really booked ever in my career I'm
averaging one every 18 years if I can go
on a run with this thing I'll be psyched
for those of you who haven't seen it and
enjoy this podcast this is not a podcast
this is just a statement but enjoy all
the other free podcasts he let me like
you know what he never comes and tours
in my area or I don't care to see his
act live but I would like to somehow pay
it forward you could pay it forward by
buying a ticket to date night you could
even be doing we have bigger favour is
if you're gonna if you've already seen
it or you don't even want to [__] see
it you'd rather see another movie do me
a favor just buy two tickets to date
night and just go into the other movie
that you wanted to anyways just so it
pads the stats date night starring Steve
Carell and Tina Fey is that a local
Cineplex near you please go see it so
anyways so we get the badges and this is
the deal you're not allowed to bring a
self
bounine you're not allowed to bring a
camera in you're not allowed to bring
video equipment in you're not allowed to
bring [__] in all you're allowed to
bring in is yourself the clothes that
cover you and some [__] cash and some
sunblock that's it
all right so you walk in there and you
literally get going through like a metal
detector like you're going through the
airport and immediately there's this
sense of is the president nearby because
that's what this security feels like and
then the big thing with these badges is
it's not like you get the badge at the
person's house or where however the [__]
you get it and you get to keep it you
have to return the badge and when you
have this badge you have the
responsibility to not break any rules
because if they kick you out they take
your badge so you'll never come again so
not only can you never come again the
person whose badge it was does not get
it back ever again no matter what
because you are obviously not good
enough a judge of character
considering that you gave this badge to
this person that we now have to eject
and and when I went there all I heard
was stories of people that they had seen
get eject some some ejected some guy
actually got a cell phone in there and
it rang at some point during the match
and people just appear out of nowhere
okay one guy puts you in a [__]
chokehold another guy snatches the badge
off your shirt in the badge has to be
displayed at all times and you would
think with all those [__] people
there if he didn't have it displayed you
had you know very small chance of
someone stopping you I didn't have my ID
mine in my pocket and I walked like ten
feet with it and this guy just appeared
out of nowhere with his master's that
green colored shirt sir was your badge
where's your badge sir sir do you have a
badge
you know [__] gun drawn he made me
reach in my pocket with two fingers you
know pull it out kid
whatever so anyways so we walk out on so
that we get there first thing we do is
we walk into the Pro Shop and I already
told myself I was gonna spend it like
400 bucks and I got dammit if I if I
didn't it's exactly what I did I got
some shot glasses I got some golf balls
I got some hats for people they actually
sell those masters the flags you know
that they have on the pins all around
there just says the Masters 2010 very
clean very elegant it's the [__] I've
bought a bunch of those for some friends
and a couple of golf shirts you know the
usual [__] and then I bought one of
those the best and the best souvenir I
ended up getting is you actually cuz you
don't want to stand up for [__] 12
hours watching people golf what's up
Cleo
how you doing I didn't know you were
laying there how you doing you guys
haven't heard of [__] moan lately
anyways umm I just do that for me
so anyways they sell these these chairs
there that you can sit on see this is
why this isn't a podcast you know what I
just said they sell these chairs that I
you can sit on is that what you do with
a chair bill and they actually end up
being one of the most coveted souvenirs
because when you go to get on the plane
the next day you see everybody got him
they got him slung over their shoulders
the way they fold up it looks like
you're carrying like a yoga mat except
it weighs like [__] 20 pounds so
anyways let's let's cut to the chase
here cuz I got to finish this statement
early um I went out onto the golf course
and those of you who are big fans of
golf and you watch the Masters every
year you got to go there because when
you go and you see the clubhouse you
can't go in it but when you see it and
you just start walking the course this
is this is what I suggest get there at
like 8:00 in the morning and start at 18
and just walk the course backwards
all the way to the front I didn't do
that because I had too much [__] that I
bought and I just walked two different
holes that I really liked but that's
what this guy told me I do walk the
whole [__] course but we got there a
little late because I was in a bar the
night before watching a guy with a box
on his head sing songs that I couldn't
really understand but anyways you go
onto the course and I've never been to
anything like this
as far as nature goes I've seen it was
like seeing famous people except they
were they were fairways like I walked up
and around so when I came to 18 I was in
between where you tee off and looking
down the fairway you know when someone's
just bringing it home and is gonna win
the Masters there's a roadway where you
walk across and I looked right down that
fairway and I don't know it's one of
those [__] things we just like this
really exists you know it isn't this is
real and then you go over to hole number
12 ain't at the little pamphlet here
they got all the holes are named the
12th hole what the [__] do they call it
they have like them that Golden Bell is
the name this is how white this is you
guys want to hear the names of the holes
now usually when I talk about holes on
the podcast it's a lot more crass than
this hole number one is called T olive
all right that's not - hole number two
is called pink dogwood tell me there
isn't a porno to be made with some of
these names flowering peach
it's the third hole these are all mildly
sexual aren't they flowery crabapple oh
that's the one where like if you're into
watching guys [__] old women this is
really just gonna get disgusting fifth
hole is Magnolia you get the point
juniper is a sixth
pompous I don't what the [__] yellow
Jasmine but whatever they got all these
flowers and everything's in bloom and
it's just it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable
like I couldn't be like when I was
coming up on to 12 to see that little
bridge there on whatever the [__] they
call it the pink petunia Golden Bell
it's just unbelievable when you see it
it's literally iconic the same feeling I
got when I saw Big Ben in London how
[__] awesome is my life this past
month when I saw Big Ben you just stare
at it you can't believe it it's just
something you've seen your whole life
and now you're standing there looking at
it and I'm telling you
the [__] urge this is the thing about
it there was so many things you can't
talk to the golfers like if Tiger hit
something hit the ball hit something his
wife if Tiger hit the [__] ball you
could literally go like you know as he
came walking up to Bali there come on
Tiger you could say something like that
maybe but that's it after you hit the
ball you can be like you the minute you
move that's it someone would pair out of
nowhere chloroform rag right over your
[__] nose somebody else Yanks off
your [__] badge and that's it they
pummel you with billy clubs that are the
same color as the Masters green and they
just beat the [__] out of you and they
toss you over the [__] fence that's
how it works but I got a mint with all
those rules all those rules the urge to
just do something like that and get
kicked out like I almost had like
Tourette's because what I ended up doing
is I settled on the 15th hole and I sat
in the bleachers and I don't know what
that one's called wispy pubic hair what
the [__] do they call this one the 15th
[__] hole is called fire thorn and it
had this this is basically what we did
we realized that there were so many
[__] people there and we had our
chairs that we had to lug around and a
foreigner dollars worth of [__] in his
bag I wasn't gonna walk 18 holes and
just follow Tiger around I didn't want
to do it because there's too many
[__] people and there's people camped
out around where they tee off and
they're camped out around the green so
what you can basically do is run down
the [__] fairway if you can get there
knowing that all the golfers have a
point A to point B once they once you
know just to keep play moving you on the
other hand have specific areas where you
can cross over fairways and that type of
[__] and if you don't they [__] they
they they destroy you and they take your
badge so we just said [__] it
we're gonna go to 15 we're gonna sit
there we can watch them hit their second
shots of par 5 and we look over our
shoulder we can't see them tee off on 16
but we can see the result of their shot
and we sat there in the bleachers and
knowing that we had a good
two and a half hours to wait until they
came I think was actually three hours so
we just sat there and you would think it
would be boring as hell and it wasn't
you just shooting the [__] with other
people older people who have gone to the
Masters since like the early 70s late
seventies one guy from like 1952 I
didn't get a chance to talk to them but
they talk about you know Nikolas win in
86 and all this [__] was you know if
you're a sports fan it was [__]
incredible and meanwhile all we're doing
is we're sitting waiting for the beer
Trappe taps to be turned on this is how
this how secretive this [__] place is
is no one had any idea when they get
turned on somebody up in the clubhouse
in the inner [__] catacombs of the
clubhouse gives everybody the go-ahead
to turn on the beer taps and they can't
even tell you when they I don't know
maybe twelve thirty maybe one we're not
sure and they don't have any advertising
so it just says domestic beer regular
beer the whole [__] thing is just
like look we're in control alright you
want an import this is import you want a
domestic this is domestic what kind is
it I can't disclose that I'm not allowed
to tell you when when you turn in the
beer on we're not allowed to tell you
sir why are you being hostile you know
so we're just sitting there and there's
a couple of turtles outside the [__]
pond then we start gambling on the
turtles which one's gonna go in the
[__] water first then they turn on
the beer and we start getting shit-faced
and we're waiting for the first [__]
golfers to come and then it's just like
the Indy 500 you just you just you just
bet on golfers it's like the most
elegant track you've ever been to and
you just wait and they coming through
two at a time
Ernie else you know Kenny Perry's coming
through [__] Sergio Valente whatever
his [__] name is either and then just
right in front of you it's the [__] and
you're just sitting there getting
hammered betting on golfers and [__]
Turtles that's what I did all day
sitting in the Sun [__] saw two holes
in one or at least the results of them I
say heard him hit the green know it hits
the green and I hear the crowd go crazy
I look oh when I see it rolling the
and everybody goes [__] nuts I lost
100 bucks on the first one and 100 on
the next one so I was even and I got a
mint - when you sit there and all of a
sudden you look and they and you know
Tigers coming next because you got like
the the whole list of golfers is [__]
unreal and you see him come over the
hill all right like a [__] one of
those deer hunters say 15 horn [__]
dare man 20 pointer coming over the hill
I got it my socks man I'm gonna chew to
ride the [__] head that was what is
like Tiger comes over the damn Hill he's
wearing he's just see him I can't even
see him he's so far away you see it guy
you see a black guy who looks like a
black guy who's actually mostly [__]
Asian or whatever the hell he is I don't
know what the hell he is you see some
tan dude beyond the tan that a white guy
can get coming over the hill with a red
shirt and the [__] black pants on you
like that's [__] Tiger Woods and a
hush just falls over the entire the
entire hole and like there's like 3,000
people sitting there and it's dead quiet
and you see that ball [__] just
flying I saw him eagle the [__] hole
I saw him eagle it I saw Kim the Korean
dude eagle it I think I saw did it was
it Ernie else that was another thing
that kind of sucked it was kind of hard
to tell if it was that second or third
you just knew with guys like Kim and and
Tiger Woods the way they drove that it
was that second shot anyways whatever it
was [__] awesome and Phil Mickelson
came in last cuz he was on the
leaderboard and once he went past us I
ran off the bleachers went down and
actually he's the only guy I watched tee
off watched him tee off on 16 and then
we grabbed our [__] and we ran over to
18 and Tiger had already finished but we
stood there halfway down the three
three-quarters of the way up the 18th at
Augusta and watched Mickelson tee off
who watched him hit his second shot and
then we couldn't see through the crowd
when he sucked the winning putt and but
we stood there and I looked between a
bunch of [__] blue bloods heads and I
watched him put the green jacket on and
get choked up when he talked about his
wife and it was one of the most
incredible experiences I've ever had and
it's making me really thankful for the
incredible [__] life I have and I
hope this isn't building resentment with
you guys you know you just lay off drink
it for a little bit you know you could
get by one of those badges by a stinking
badge and go next year just do one thing
do one [__] thing you know I don't
[__] know I don't know what I'm
saying this is just this is just my
statement that I'm not doing a podcast
this week I'm not [__] doing it but I
know you can you can go there those cost
me 600 bucks I know that's a lot of
[__] money I know it is but think how
much money you blow each weekend in a
bar
alright figure out what you blow each
weekend in a bar here's a good way to do
it here's a nice healthy way and just
just go on the wagon for a while and
then just take the money that you would
have spent on booze you put it into your
Augusta fund
no I just [__] drive there do a [__]
road trip get yourself a pair of Dockers
and a golf shirt alright have a nice and
pressed and clean drive like a goddamn
maniac both you and your buddy even if
you live in Seattle trade-off drive all
the [__] way down there going to
somebody's house get debriefed walk in
there act like a gentleman and get to
see something that most people never get
to see and what's great is they're all
the souvenirs they don't really sell
anything on the internet so that's why
you buy a ton of [__] is because
everybody asks you to get him some stuff
and even if they don't you got you got
great gifts for the rest of the year you
know he can do all your Christmas
shopping right there you get somebody a
[__] hat at the Masters they're gonna
be psyched because no one else is gonna
have that [__] hat unless they went
there so there you go now that's the end
of my statement for this week people 38
minutes statement actually flew back
this morning and
I was I was an idiot I guess something
like I was I was a little more buzz than
I thought it was and I was really tired
when I got three hours sleep I'm [__]
embarrassed I yelled at a cop
when I drove out of the masters it was
like it was really late because we stuck
around to the end and it was like he was
we sat through this [__] traffic and
all I had to do was make a left and
drive like 40 yards down the road and I
could jump on the [__] highway and I
was on my way and I was exhausted and I
wanted to go to sleep and what ends up
happening it's one of those deals where
the cops decide that everybody's gonna
go right we're forcing everyone right
and I want to go left so I can go a [__]
hair down the street and get on the
highway so I got my window down like I
can't go left the guy there not it could
keep going so I'm driving them and I
know what they're doing so I get to the
third cop I see a gas station I'm just
like I just want to get some gas can I
get some gas guys like keep it go and
keep it moving
I just want what I can't get some gas
just like that [__] screamed at him
as I drove by cuz he was on foot and cuz
I was a little drunk and I drove away
and all sudden I was couldn't feel my
legs going like that I just [__] do
that as a Yankee in the middle of
[__] Georgia did I just yell at that
guy clearly though was I just obnoxious
and then I was like I don't give a [__]
and the first left I could make I made a
left and then I banged one of the most
illegal [__] u-turns hybrid
three-point [__] turns and there were
two cops sitting right there and my
buddy's like doo doo doo doo doot which
is universal for there's a cop dodo dodo
dodo and I was like yeah I don't give a
[__] he's like what's wrong with you
and I'm like a little I'm a little
buzzed and I'm a control freak don't
[__] tell me where I can't go I've
been on that goddamn golf course every
day all I wanted to do was run out of
the bleachers on somebody's approaching
shot on 15 and do a [__] cannonball
right into that little mini lake
alrighty had it planned out was gonna
give my badge to my buddy and tell him
dude take a walk
dude what do you mean take just take a
[__] walk and he'd see at my eyes and
be like all right man and he just
grabbed my [__] he just walk away and
then what I would do is I do a
cannonball right
the [__] Lake okay and I would
immediately be a [__] legend an
absolute [__] legend on the Don
jackass calm if there's something you
know I'd be right up there with fan man
that [__] kid at Yankee Stadium who
jumped off into the into the the the
backstop netting I don't know who else
that dude who ran out and grabbed the
football and got slammed down to the
ground by the linebacker on Monday Night
Football I'd be one of those guys I'd be
put on that [__] you know whacked-out
sports or whatever I would I would be on
that [__] forever and then when they
asked me when they pulled me out of
there you know they went to grab my
badge I wouldn't have it where's your
badge
I don't know must be at the bottom of
the pond they have Thurston why don't
you take off your loafers and roll up
your slacks and go in there and try and
find it what's the worst she gonna do to
me prosecute me to the fullest extent of
the law
you know they know every big judge in
the state I probably still be in [__]
prison but I gotta admit I don't know so
anyway so then I just drove the rest the
[__] away home I stopped at Arby's went
to bed at [__] 12:00 midnight had to
get up at 6:30 and I got on a [__]
plane I had a muffin I had M&Ms and
there was a baby crying the whole way
and I don't give a [__] I know I never
care when babies cry on planes
I don't give a [__] but there was some
square headed cut in front of me who
kept turning around looking at him you
know I was like all right that's the
career woman who hates kids
I see why she's looking at him she
didn't want to have kids so she's
annoyed with their presence and then I
see she has a wedding ring and what's
what's there's only one reason to get
married that's they have kids okay so
I'm looking at her like she must be the
worst mother ever because every time
this kid cries she turns around starts
looking for her mother shooting alert
shooting her look shaking her heads and
I just want to be asked you know it's a
[__] baby
- [__] bass she had a baby man it's a
[__] baby it is unbelievable when I
hate when people do that [__] it's like
how do you not understand like you know
we're in a pressurized cabin the thing
does the betta thing the baby doesn't
how to clear its ears
it's a [__] baby stupid [__] so one
point I [__] she looked and I gave
her such a dirty look for [__] given
the mother a dirty looked at when her
[__] eyes met my eyes she looked at
me like surprised at first and then
realized that she was being a [__] and
she tried to play it off with this smile
like yeah isn't it cute isn't it cute
that the baby's crying too late I've
already judged you you're a horrible
mother and you're a horrible person and
this ends this is the conclusion of my
statement 43 minutes said that I am NOT
doing a podcast this week I regret to
inform all of you that due to
circumstances beyond your control our
host this week Bilborough abused his
body to such a [__] level that he had
an inability to do a podcast this week
and only had an ability to you know I
should have done I in the spirit of the
masters what I should have done was I
should have issued an apology just like
Tiger Woods and droned on for 45 minutes
boring the [__] out of you oh wait a
minute I think I already did that I
believe I already did that all right
that's the podcast for this week
once again I'm so sorry that I couldn't
give you a podcast this week I couldn't
give you some laughs I will be coming
out [__] I'll give you both barrels
next week speaking of which I'm gonna be
at the funny bone in Newport Kentucky
right across the river from Cincinnati
and I got to be honest with you guys I
got I already have a new killer hour
that's right I said it I said it all
right maybe it's not a killer hour it's
like 40 minutes out of the hour I
already have 40 new [__] minutes how
you like that [__] I just taped a
special in December all right we're
midway through April and I already can
run my [__]
mouth for 40 minutes with some new [__]
provided them on if I'm off I have eight
new minutes that's where my act is that
but I'm not gonna allow you I talked
about Tiger Woods for like 11 minutes
the other night all of its funny
crushing destroying I was so psyched but
in the back of my head I'm like you
realize that now after he plays the
Masters that you know I can only tell
that story for so long it's basically
mid-may it's gonna be an old story it
already is I'm still talking about that
lady who got killed at Sea World I'm
gonna give you a little preview for what
I'll be talking about am i talking about
my trip to church I went again by the
way when again on Easter I went on
Easter Sunday you know my girlfriend's
mom wanted to go to church didn't want
to go by herself so I said alright I'll
go with you we all went a little happy
family I went there sat there bored
shitless it was extra packed took
forever to eat that piece of cardboard
at the end of it or whatever a lot of
offensive thing you want me to say I
don't know I literally am like sitting
here I'm laying here right now and I
have I'm like my eyes are squinting like
there's a doctor and he's like you know
I [__] up my elbow and he's like it
tell me and told me does this hurt does
this yeah yeah it hurt yeah right there
I'm literally doing that right now
as I'm doing this [__] podcast I got
nothing all right
I had nothing for you this week and I'm
the first one to tell to you and I you
know what I say actually did this start
of this podcast like six [__] times I
forget if I said this but uh somebody
sent me a really nasty email yelling
cursing me out because they sent me an
email and I didn't answer their email
and he said because you didn't answer my
email I didn't go to see any of your
shows in Atlanta and
I don't know if I already talked about
this I apologize if I didn't sir I don't
give a [__] all right if you haven't
learned anything from my podcast is I
really don't give a [__] I don't give a
[__] if you listen to this or you don't
I don't give a [__] if you go to my
shows but you don't I don't give a [__]
you know do I do I not want people to
come to my shows of course I do do I not
want people listen my podcast of course
I don't I want [__] I think I got you
know I got messed up there and those
double negatives I want people to come
to my shows I want people this is my
podcast but let me tell you something
right now [__] oh I don't respond to
[__] threats don't [__] threaten
me or no [__] you know try to put
some sort of ominous [__] on how you
want me to [__] behave with your
[__] email I don't give a [__] about
you email I get the [__] hundreds of
emails every goddamn week and if I don't
get to yours I don't [__] get to
yours so go [__] yourself if you want to
pout and not come to my show don't go to
my show I don't give a [__] you sound
like a [__] anyways you probably go to
my show and then [__] judge it and be
like old the first eight minutes were
good and then I do it from minute 12 to
17 go [__] yourself all right why don't
you go stick your head through your
[__] computer monitor God knows you
probably still have one of those old
ones you know shaped like a [__]
microwave is that what you got
as you work look how fast people driving
this [__] Street I'm literally
getting to that age yelling out the
window what kids stop driving like I did
at your age there's another good
character for a sketch you know crabby
honest old man honest crabby old man
[Laughter]
stop treating me with the same
disrespect I had from my elders when I
was at your age or maybe not
[__] God knows SNL could turn that into
I get 15 minutes sketch and then stretch
it into an hour and 40 minute movie um
all right there we go I burned a bridge
I burned a bridge there like I was going
to get
asked on that at 41 maybe I could didn't
Phil Harmon get on old or what I
perceived to be old when he got on he's
probably like 34 at the time which was
ancient to me and now at my age I would
love to be I would love to be [__] 34
again ah to be that age um you know I'm
you know what's great about when I was
have [__] when I was 34 I could run
like [__] seven nine forty when I was
30 when I was 34 it was a very good year
my [__] dog just licked the bottom my
foot it's a goddamn freak I didn't have
a dog that [__] on the floor or needed
to go outside I did what I wanted I went
down waterslides when I was 34 what's up
Cleo how you doing
you know psyched I wants to see you you
know it's like to see you because you
were psyched to see me yeah we're always
psyched to see me aren't you you know my
dog actually misses me comes into the
bedroom at night and it [__] looks
around for me then it runs into my
little office area looking for me right
if I'm not around who are you gonna
wrestle with me see if I can get you to
moon you won't do it will you you know
you are you like that [__] frog and
Bugs Bunny yeah big big watch about my
pair then all of a sudden I bring in
somewhere hey Cleo
let me see if I can get you to howl you
want to go outside Cleo this is gonna be
worth if people just listen Cleo
you wanna go side
huh Cleo Cleo hey she's getting psyched
Cleo you wanna go outside Cleo Cleo I
wonder how come on Cleo you want to go
outside
Clio
but you [__] do it please clear you
might go aside
one more side
Clio oh you [__] burning me right now
Clio hey [__] it
Clio
to my side
Clio you know what go [__] yourself
Jesus Christ what was that three minutes
you blew it Cleo why won't you howl for
these people in in conclusion there is
no podcast this week I regret to inform
you don't come over now don't come over
now you want some food you want to go
outside
Cleo only need one more tip
hmm Clio
ah Jesus green oh this is like you don't
you mean right now you Lisa you know the
hot chick that'll never [__] you and she
just keeps giving you a glimmer of
hoping to keep coming back you keep
coming back whatever I still love you
Cleo you know even though he just made
me look like a [__] [__]
you really did that was literally the
Buehler anybody anybody all right that
concludes my statement that's the
statement I'm sticking by it's all in
the police report as Tiger Woods would
say there you go there's another thing
you should do pick one of these [__]
things to do and if one of you guys ends
up doing something that I told you to do
and you enjoy it please send me an email
like a year from now if you go to the
masters let me [__] know all right
because I think I'm gonna go again next
year that's how much [__] fun I had
or go to England do some [__] do
something
but [__] sakes all right I'll talk to
you next week
[Music]